hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast innovation gin hepatology fire
markers for hepatocellular carcinoma and
surveillance and management patients
with chronic liver disease and who do
our collaboration I'll be your moderator
for today's event all right
today's webcast is presented by
labyrinth comm the leading social media
site for science professional and
sponsored by Abbott Abbott is a global
health care company devoted to improving
life through the development of products
and technologies that span the breadth
of health care Abbott stirs people in
more than 150 countries and employs
approximately 74,000 people as a global
leader in the large and growing in vitro
diagnostic market the company develops
customer focused solutions that enhance
clinical decision making and improve the
lives of patients in an effort to help
doctors determine how to best treat
their patients and has pioneered
innovative ways to screen diagnose and
monitor a vast range of health
conditions with greater speed accuracy
and efficiency with the best information
available doctors can make treatment
decisions faster as a result Abbott has
become a leading name in immunoassay
Diagnostics blood screening bedside
testing and companion diagnostics for
more information please visit
www.archives.gov broadcast so please ask
questions or leave us a comment
answers are welcome to you can do this
by hitting the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
and typing in your comments and
questions we'll try to get to as many as
the 10 and we'll follow up if we don't
have time today on a better look you can
enlarge the slide window by clicking on
the screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you can't
hear or see this presentation properly
let us know by clicking on the support
button on the top right or use the Q&A
button
make sure we try to resolve any issues
now let's get right to today's presenter
we are proud to welcome Annette and gall
MD dr. Singhal is an associate professor
of medicine and medical director of the
liver tumor program at UT Southwestern
Medical Center is board-certified in
gastroenterology and transplant
hepatology by the American Board of
Internal Medicine dr. dr. Singhal is a
member of several professional society
committee and serves as chair of the
international liver cancer Association
surveillance and biomarkers special
interest group he is on the editorial
boards of several journals including
seminars in liver disease clinical
gastroenterology and hepatology clinical
translational gastroenterology and claus
medicine dr. Stengel has published over
50 peer-reviewed scientific papers and
over 20 review articles and textbook
chapters on hepatocellular carcinoma a
poll question will now appear on your
screen please select your answer and
then close the poll by clicking on the X
in the right corner thank you I will now
turn the presentation over to dr. Singh
all thanks Judy so as you heard today we
will be talking about a cellular
carcinoma surveillance and the potential
role of biomarkers as you've heard the
program is sponsored by Abbott and all
contents in the presentation related to
Abbott products is consistent with
applicable requirements my disclosures
you can see on the slide here of most
note I am on the speaker Bureau and
serve as a consultant to Bayer as well
as has been on an advisory board for
Waco Diagnostics in terms of the talk
today we will start by discussing the
efficacy of HCC surveillance to improve
survival primarily in patients with
cirrhosis we will then move on to
discuss the efficacy and effectiveness
of ultrasound and other imaging based
modalities as this serves the base of
HCC surveillance in most countries we
will then move on to discussing
alternative imaging mode
and some of the data supporting or not
supporting using alternate imaging
modalities and finally the majority of
our talk we will be discussing the use
of other biomarkers including alpha beta
protein AF P l3 and of course physica -
so to start hepatocellular carcinoma is
the fifth most common tumor worldwide
and the third leading cause of
cancer-related death as you can see from
this map the highest incidence rates of
HCC are in East Asia and Africa and this
is related to high rates of endemic
chronic hepatitis B however its
incidence in those areas is on the
decline related to increased hepatitis B
vaccination programs and higher rates of
hepatitis C treatment among at-risk
individuals although it has an
intermediate risk intermediate rate in
the United States and Canada its
incidence is on the rise over the last
10 year period assessed by seer a large
cancer registry in the United States HCC
has the largest increase in incidence
among all solid tumors in parallel with
the rapidly rising incidence rate HCC
also has the fastest-growing death rate
you can see from this figure that we are
actually doing a very good job with most
cancers and the mortality rate for those
cancers is actually declining however
when you go to the bottom of the slide
you can see that the mortality rate for
liver cancer has nearly doubled over the
same 10-year period as most people know
the most important risk factor for HCC
is the presence of underlying liver
disease patients with underlying liver
disease go through cycles of
inflammation and repair eventually
leading to cirrhosis which is the key
underlying risk factor for many patients
with HCC with resultant to genomic
instability in the setting of cirrhosis
somatic mutations lead to the formation
of dysplastic nodules and eventually HCC
although many patients in East Asia and
Africa do not have cirrhosis they often
still have underlying liver disease with
high rates of non cirrhotic chronic
hepatitis B the large majority of HCC
cases in the United States
and Europe actually occur in the setting
of cirrhosis even those patients who
have chronic hepatitis B understanding
the local at-risk population is
important when it comes to early
detection as it highlights the at-risk
population to which surveillance efforts
should be targeted prognosis for HCC is
largely driven by tumor stage at the
time of diagnosis if HACC is found at an
early stage patients are amenable to
curative therapies such as ablation
resection or transplantation and they
can achieve 5-year survival rates
approaching 70% patients have founded an
intermediate stage are only a metabolic
palliative therapies including chemo
embolization or radioembolization and
the median survival is close to two
years patients founded an advanced stage
have a median survival less than one
year even with our best chemo therapies
at this point unfortunately most HCC at
least in the United States continue to
be detected at a late stage you can see
data from seer that only a minority of
HCC cases are diagnosed at a local stage
although this has improved over time you
can see that the majority of cases still
are found at a distant stage instead of
a localized stage and as we discussed
previously this is crucial given a
strong association between tumor stage
and survival rates as you can see on the
right hand side of the slide with the
one-year survival rates to improve early
detection and overall survival several
societies have recommended HCC
surveillance in high-risk patients
including those with cirrhosis with most
societies recommending surveillance
using ultrasound every six months the
these societies include the major liver
societies from the United States Europe
and Asia the best data for HCC
surveillance is a randomized study among
19,000 patients with chronic hepatitis B
there were approximately 9,500 patients
who were randomized to undergo
surveillance with ultrasound and
alpha-fetoprotein
and approximately 9,500 patients who are
randomized to no screening patients who
underwent surveillance had a
significantly
a portion of tumors detected at an early
stage facility facilitating receipt of
curative treatments most importantly the
trial demonstrated that HTC surveillance
using a combination of ultrasound and
al-qaeda protein reduced mortality by 37
percent it should be noted that this
prior study was conducted in patients
with chronic hepatitis B and these
results may not be applicable to
patients with cirrhosis given increased
liver nodularity and higher rates of
liver dysfunction although there are no
similar randomized control trials
evaluating the benefits of HCC
surveillance and patients with cirrhosis
this benefit has been demonstrated in
federal court studies here you can see
results from a meta-analysis of several
cohort studies in which we were able to
highlight the association between HCC
surveillance and detection of HCC at an
early stage studies demonstrated a
fairly consistent benefit from HCC
surveillance with a pooled two-fold
increased odds of finding HCC at an
early stage we also found a strong
association with improved survival with
a two-fold odds increased the two fold
increased odds for 3 year survival
however this analysis is limited by
notable limitations including lead time
and month time biases given that these
studies were cohort studies and non
randomized among the several cohort
studies that had evaluated the
association between HCC surveillance and
improve survival there were five that
statistically adjusted for lead time
bias and here you can see the results
from these five studies notably all five
studies continue to show a strong
association between HCC surveillance and
improved survival after adjusting for
lead time bias the ability for HCC
surveillance to improve survival is
largely predicated on the availability
of ethic asia surveillance tools this
systematic review identified 12 studies
that evaluated the efficacy of
ultrasound to detect HEC at an early
stage and you can see that ultrasound
had a pooled sensitivity of 63% for
detecting HEC
at an early stage among these
prospective cohort studies we found that
adding elpida protein to ultrasound
increased the sensitivity to 69%
although this difference did not reach
statistical significance
despite the in data surveillance failure
is one of the most common reasons for
late stage tumor detection in clinical
practices this was a study conducted
among patients with advanced HCC
detected in academic centers involved in
Hall C which was a prospective cohort
study because I prospective randomized
trial in patients with hepatitis C we
found that failure of detection was the
most common reason for late stage tumor
detection surveillance failure was
attributed to an absence of detection
meaning that the surveillance tests
they'll define the tumor in nearly 61
percent of patients who were found to
have tumors beyond
TNM stage t1 and 70% of those who were
detected beyond Milan criteria these
data suggest that we need better
surveillance tools to improve early
stage detection in clinical practice
these poor outcomes are in part related
to the gap between efficacy and
effectiveness of ultrasound in clinical
practice so let's quickly review what
these two terms mean efficacy describes
the performance of a test under ideal
circumstances so that's performed in the
best patients by the best providers with
the best equipment effectiveness
describes the performance of a test
under real-world circumstances where
patients can be non-compliant they may
have comorbid conditions providers may
have lower levels of knowledge about
treatments or simply forget to do
something and where equipment may not be
top of the line or the newest model in
this table you can see how a more
efficacious test that is therapy B can
be less effective if there is less
access less uptake by providers and or
less patient adherence
need and suggest that ultrasound does
not appear to perform as well when used
in clinical practice so this is a study
where we assess the effectiveness of
surveillance ultrasound in nearly 450
patients with cirrhosis of whom 41
developed ACC after a median of 3.5
years given that this was an
effectiveness study ultrasounds were
performed as part of clinical care and
many patients receive surveillance
testing locally out in the community
instead of at the tertiary care
University Hospital we found in this
study that ultrasound only had a
sensitivity of 44% of subs for HCC at
any stage and disappointingly low at 32%
to find tumors at an early stage so
comparing the figures of efficacy and
effectiveness back to back you can see
that there truly is a large gap between
the efficacy and effectiveness of
ultrasound for detecting HCC at an early
stage although its sensitivity could be
as high as 63% and prospective cohort
studies
when conducted by experts and high
volume centers its sensitivity was
nearly half that at only 32% when
conducted by average stenographers in
the real world clinical setting so the
gap between ultrasounds efficacy and
effectiveness could potentially be
related to several factors first
ultrasound is thought to be operator
dependent so it's sensitivity likely
varies with operator experience and
knowledge a better knowledge base
regarding liver anatomy and the ability
to simultaneously interpret images while
scanning may yield higher sensitivity
rates furthermore patient
characteristics such as obesity and or
liver nodularity may also impact
ultrasound sensitivity for early stage
HCC detection this has been seen in
other diagnostic tests such as the
impact of breast density on the
sensitivity of mammography or female
gender on the accuracy of treadmill
stress tests and
last couple of years there's been a
couple studies that have started to
evaluate what factors may impact
ultrasound to accuracy so the first was
a retrospective analysis of a
multicenter italian database with nearly
1200 patients and in this study del pol
geo and colleagues found that ultrasound
failure occurred in approximately 30% of
cases the good news is that this
decrease from 33% of cases in the 1990s
to only one-fourth of the cases in mm
they found that surveillance was success
was higher in child QA patients than
those with more advanced liver disease
suggesting that liver nodularity truly
plays a role in ultrasound sensitivity
they also found that HCC surveillance
was associated with features consistent
with aggressive tumor biology suggesting
that surveillance failure may not only
be related to operator dependency but
also in some cases related to bad tumor
biology if this is the case then really
improving on surveillance sensitivity
may not be able to detect all tumors at
an early stage
however this retrospective analysis
could only establish association not
necessarily causality and further
research in this area is still needed
we recently performed a subsequent
retrospective cohort studies among
patients who underwent ultrasound exam
for cirrhosis related indication between
April 2015 and October 2015
Green fellowship trained abdominal
radiologists collectively reviewed all
of these ultrasound exams and
categorized the exam quality as
definitely adequate likely adequate
likely inadequate and definitely
inadequate to exclude liver lesions
based on anatomic coverage visual
clarity of the livers and or other exam
limitations
so among 941 patients we found that 20%
of ultrasounds were inadequate for HTT
surveillance 134 which were categorized
as definitely inadequate and 5257 exams
that were categorized as likely
inadequate in multivariate analysis we
found that inadequate
quality was associated with male gender
body mass index category Chau Q B or C
cirrhosis alcohol-related cirrhosis nash
cirrhosis and performing the ultrasound
exam while the patient was an inpatient
we found that ultrasounds were
inadequate in over one-third of patients
who had a BMI greater than 35 or Nash
cirrhosis which is highly concerning
that given that these have got to be
that these are thought to reflect the
future epidemiology of HCC in many parts
of the world so potential solutions to
ultrasound support effectiveness include
use of imaging with higher sensitivities
or combining ultrasound with biomarkers
over the next few slides we will discuss
data evaluating each of these options
focusing primarily on the value of
adding biomarkers in combination with
ultrasound rather than alternate imaging
modalities so given limitations of
ultrasound there are some who use CT or
MRI for HCC surveillance in clinical
practice a recent national survey in the
United States found the distractors was
particularly common in centers with a
liver transplant program there are a few
high quality data evaluating CT or MRI
for HCC surveillance with most studies
evaluating these modalities simply in a
diagnostic fashion as far as I'm aware
this is the only study evaluating CT for
HCC surveillance here you can see data
from a small randomized trial in which
163 patients were randomized to
semiannual surveillance ultrasound or
annual surveillance CT and then followed
for an average of three years over this
time period there were eight HECS in
each arm with no differences in early
detection or HCC related mortality
between the two arms with the caveat
that of course these numbers are very
small of note there was a higher rate of
nonspecific nodules in the CT are
resulting in more follow-up testing
despite once again a similar proportion
of patients being found in the early
stage and as expected Ct surveillance
with
Stanly more costly per agency detected
than ultrasound based surveillance this
abstracted ace I'll be a couple years
ago was one of the first to evaluate MRI
in a surveillance matter this is a
prospective cohort study involving 407
patients with child QA or these
cirrhosis who are then followed for a
median of 1.5 years yielding a total of
1112 surveillance rounds over this time
queued 35 patients developed HCC with 26
having very early stage tumors and an
additional 8 having early stage tumors
according to the BC LC staging criteria
the sensitivity of MRI was significantly
higher than that of ultrasounds for both
HCC overall as well as very early-stage
HCC however the authors did not perform
a cost analysis comparing these two
modalities and you can see from these
numbers that you would imagine that MRI
would not be cost-effective in this
fashion given the fact that you had to
do over 1,000 MRI exams to detect a
small fraction of HEC at an early stage
compared to ultrasound based
surveillance so it's clear that better
biomarkers are needed and likely paint
the future of HCC surveillance there
have been several studies examining
biomarkers including outside of protein
of AFP l3 and pisca to being some of the
best-known there are several other
biomarkers that are currently undergoing
biomarker phase 2 and phase 3
development studies so before going into
data for each of the biomarkers I just
wanted to quickly review the recommended
5 phases of biomarker development the
first phase is biomarker identification
which is typically done through
preclinical studies once this is done
the next phase is case control studies
that characterized the ability of a
biomarker to distinguish HCC versus non
HCC although you will see variability in
studies including some that we will
present today the
most important factor in these studies
is distinguishing HCC from cirrhosis or
chronic hepatitis B infection not
distinguishing HCC from normal patients
or other cancers per se once again going
but back to the fact that HTC typically
happens in the setting of chronic liver
disease furthermore it's important to
focus on the performance of a biomarker
to detect early HCC because this is
really the goal of HCC surveillances to
find take patients at an early stage not
simply to detect HCC at any stage and
unfortunately most buyer markets do a
much better job detecting advanced HCC
but once again this is not helpful in
clinical practice and once again as
you'll see in several other studies that
we present there's often a mix of
early-stage HCC and advanced HEC in
several of these studies and when
looking at the data it's really
important to focus on the performance
for early-stage HCC the third phase is
retrospective longitudinal studies which
determines the ability of a biomarker to
detect preclinical HCC that is HCC once
again at an early stage this phase is
also important for determining the best
cutoff to use in phase four studies
phase four studies are prospective
cohort studies in which these biomarkers
are included in the management algorithm
and diagnostic tests are actually
performed if any of those biomarkers are
positive this will help establish
performance characteristics including
sensitivity and specificity when
actually implemented in clinical
practice and finally phase five studies
are randomized control trials in which
clinical benefits and harms among a
target population can best be determined
as you'll see over the next few slides
alpha-fetoprotein is the only biomarker
that's actually completed all five
phases of biomarker development with
most of the other biomarkers having only
completed phase 2 studies so let's start
by discussing AFP the best characterize
and most commonly used biomarker and
clinical practice as many of you know
there is great debate if AFP should be
included in HCC surveillance it was
included in
prior guideline as a potential adjunct
to ultrasound but was recently removed
from the mom from the Ald as well as
either guidelines given imperfect
sensitivity and specificity now there
are many people who still believe AFP
can add value and improve early
detection and clinical practice for as
many folks who believe in AFP there are
several others who still contest that
ASP is imperfectly sensitive and
specific for routine use an HCC
surveillance and here you can see some
of the title some commentaries that have
declared the death of AFP and HCC
surveillance so let's take a step back
from this debate and actually examine
some of the data surrounding this issue
the first thing is that most people will
agree that AFP should not be used in
isolation for agency surveillance
there's very little debate about this it
should be used in combination with
imaging in this meta-analysis evaluating
AFP performance characteristics five
studies met inclusion criteria and were
analyzed the overall quality of evidence
was felt to be limited only one study
universally applied an acceptable gold
standard test three of the five studies
use a case control design that
potentially overestimated diagnostic
accuracy using the most commonly
reported cutoff of 20 nanograms per
milliliter sensitivity of AFP ranged
anywhere from 41 to 65% specificity from
80 to 94% the authors of this
meta-analysis concluded that AFP has
limited accuracy for HCC surveillance
when used in isolation
however ASP appears to be a benefit when
added to all of herself at least in
clinical practice while once again going
back to the beginning discussing the
efficacy data while AFP was not a
significant benefit in prospective
cohort studies and you can see once
again the sensitivity for early stage
tumors went from 63 to 69% it appears to
be a benefit when used in real-world
clinical settings so taking a look at
the effectiveness setting this is once
again going back to that study that was
conducted among 450 patients with
cirrhosis
we found the elf adding
alpha-fetoprotein to ultrasound in
clinical practice significantly
increased sensitivity for early stage
detection ultrasound alone once again
had a sensitivity of 32% for finding
tumors in early stage and this was
doubled to 63%
when adding alpha-fetoprotein so these
data suggest that Alfreda protein may be
of additional benefit in some cases
particularly when ultrasound quality may
not be ideal now for the skeptics who
are on this webinar who think that
ultrasounds only had limitations in that
single Center study you can actually see
similar data from the hall see cohort so
to quickly review this is a study
evaluating maintenance if you're on
among 1050 patients with hepatitis C
infection and advanced fibrosis this was
a secondary analysis in which the
authors characterized the accuracy of
HEC surveillance tests most notably
ultrasound and alpha protein to detect
HEC at an early stage and similar to
what we observed in our single Center
study ultrasound only detected one third
of a cc at an early stage an alpha beta
protein substantially improved
sensitivity for early-stage htc
detection going from 36% all the way up
to 51% now most studies to date have
only assessed one time measurements of
AFP instead of serial AFP levels and of
course this doesn't accurately reflect
how we interpret data in clinical
practice when we see patients in clinic
we use all data including prior
measurements and the current
measurements so this is a study using
data once again from home see where we
found longitudinal measurements of
al-qaeda protein along with patient
specific risk factors had higher
accuracy for HCC detection than using
one-time L theta protein measurements
you can see that using this ROC analysis
but using longitudinal measurements had
an area under the curve of approximately
0.8 which is actually very accurate so
to quickly review on AUC interpretation
an AUC
0.5 is essentially a coin flip and in
highways a non helpful test whereas an
AUC of 1.0 is perfect and so an AUC of
0.8 is regarded as being highly accurate
furthermore most studies have assumed
that ASP performs equally well in all
patients independent of liver disease
etiology or severity
however patient characteristics can
significantly influence the performance
of AFP with a markedly higher
specificity in hepatitis c negative
patients similarly others have reported
that the specificity of AFP can be
improved by adjusting for alt level as a
surrogate for hepatic inflammation
therefore these data suggests that AFP
may be used in some patient subgroups
such as those without viral hepatitis
this is particularly important to keep
in mind as the epidemiology of HCC
shifts from hepatitis B related to
natural ated in many parts of the world
finally although ASP is imperfect when
used alone it may be possible to develop
an algorithm to increase AFP accuracy so
we know that AFP levels are not only
influenced by the presence of HCC but
also underlying severity and activity of
liver disease at any given any given AFP
level low platelets low alt and overage
are associated with increased risk of
HCC so this is a study that was recently
published in gastroenterology and gives
you a nice algorithm for interpreting
these AFP levels after adjusting for
other values including age alt and
platelet count and taking a look at this
you can see that a 70 year old patient
with an AFP level of 20 the predicted
risk of HCC in the next 6 to 12 months
can significantly vary from less than
10% to over 50% as a platelet count and
alt decrease so although that although
AFP has promised and is useful in some
patients and it can be improved by some
of these modalities it's still clear
that better biomarkers are needed so for
we'll discuss AFP l-3 the grosser form
that represents the LCA bound reaction
of AFP AFP al3 is thought to be the
fraction of AFP that is produced by HTC
in early stages and the initial thought
was that this should be more accurate
for early tumor detection than AFP as a
whole
AFP l3 is reported as a percentage of
AFP unfortunately early studies hampered
enthusiasm for the biomarker given lower
sensitivity than expected for early
tumor detection AF pl3 only had a
sensitivity of 37% for early HTC in the
Phase two
early detection research Network study
and only 25% in a secondary analysis
using halt C data since those data the
company has introduced a more sensitive
assays was sure to hopefully improve
accuracy as we move forward in addition
to higher sensitivity the SI also allows
reporting of AF pl3 results among those
with normal AFP results so this was a
phase two study in which authors compare
compare the conventional afplt athlete
to the new athlete among 74 patients
with cirrhosis and 94 with HCC overall
the sensitivity of AFP l3 was
significantly higher with the new assay
45 percent versus 13% of importance the
increased sensitivity was most marked
for early-stage tumors defined as TNM
stage t1 in this study both assays
appeared to work well in late stage
tumors although once again this is less
clinically important
similarly this study among 396 chronic
liver disease and 270 HTC patients
compared the conventional and the new
assay
among patients in whom aft AFP did not
work that is all patients in the study
had an AFP level less than 20 nanograms
per milliliter as you can see the
sensitivity for HEC at any stage were
significantly higher for the new assays
42% versus seven percent although it did
have a lower specificity of the 85
percent versus 90 99 percent
of note on the right hand side of the
slide you can see that the sensitivity
for early tumor detection was also
significantly better 35% versus only 5%
for the conventional assays
something else worth noting from the
study which will be discussed over the
next few slides is a complementary
nature of the biomarkers AFP l3 and
Pisgah to AFP l3 had a sensitivity of
35% when used alone Pisgah to 20% when
used alone but the two had a higher
sensitivity of 45% when used in
combination finally the last biomarker
we will discuss in detail will be Pisgah
to pick the two is an abnormal protein
protein that is generated through
acquired defect in post post
translational carboxylation this process
occurs in the liver but is impaired in
patients with had a cellular carcinoma
because of its nature it is important to
note that Pitka 2 will be falsely of
normal in patients who are on coumadin
for or who are vitamin K deficient
similar to ASP l3 some of the early
studies hampered enthusiasm for Pisgah 2
for example a secondary analysis of data
from the Hulk's II trial in patients
with hepatitis C infection demonstrated
a sensitivity of 55% for HEC at any
stage however there have been subsequent
studies which have rekindled enthusiasm
for this biomarkers and we will review
these over the next few slides so this
study included 219 patients with
hepatitis B related cirrhosis and 157
HCC of whom just under 30% had univocal
tumors less than 3 centimeters in
maximum diameter so the one thing of
note when interpreting the overall data
is that many of these patients had
larger tumors there were also 879
patients with non cirrhotic chronic
hepatitis B which we will not be
discussing those data in today's webinar
you can see that the sensitivities of
AFP and Pitka - were 59 percent and 74
percent respectively the sensitivity of
Pisgah - was too
basically higher than that of AFP with a
p-value of 0.05 although it had a lower
specificity of 90% vs. 97% the AUC for
early stage HCC was 0.71 for AFP and
0.75 for Pisgah 2 which was not
significantly different between the two
groups with a p-value of 0.5 1
unfortunately the AUC for the two
biomarkers in combination detect early
HCC was not reported in this study the
second study of interest in one from
China including 75 patients with
cirrhosis primarily have types be
related as one would expect and 236
patients with HCC once again the study
also had patients with cirrhosis without
cirrhosis but we were not going to
discuss the non throughout data in this
presentation similar to the prior study
pivot to demonstrated a significantly
higher sensitivity for HCC at any stage
73 percent versus 59 percent however the
AUC 482 detection was similar between
the biomarker between the two biomarkers
for early stage detection at 0.82 and
0.81 using the two in combination
increased the AUC for early tumor
detection to 0.86
suggesting that the two may have added a
value and may be useful to use together
the final pivot to study we will review
today is the phase 2 early detection
research Network study from the United
States which included 417 patients with
cirrhosis and 419 patients with HCC the
patients had a mix of liver disease
ideologies including 60% to a hepatitis
C and 35% to a non-viral liver disease
nearly half of the HCC were early stage
tumors present barcelona clinic liver
cancer staging system the sensitivity
for early htc detection was 53% for AFP
and 61% for Pisgah 2 of note once again
using the two in combination resulted in
a substantially higher sensitivity for
early detection of 7
8% the authors conducted a post hoc
subgroup analysis comparing viral versus
non viral ideology and they found that
AFP had similar sensitivity specificity
an area under the curve for early HTC
detection between non viral and viral
ideologies of liver disease the same did
not appear to be the case or Pisgah to
Pisgah to a lower sensitivity an area
among area under the curve among non
viral patients than buggle patients with
an area under the curve of 0.75 and
viral patients and 0.65 in non viral
patients once again the common theme you
can see here is that using the two in
combination resulted in higher
performance compared to AFP alone in
both subgroups Allroad the benefit
appeared abusing the two in combination
appeared to be less pronounced and non
viral patients the authors examined the
biomarker distribution of the two
biomarkers which highlights the
complementary nature of the biomarkers
first you can note that there are many
patients who had both elevated AFP and
Pisgah two levels as you can see in this
circle however there are some patients
who only had asked elevated AFP levels
and others who only had elevated BCP
levels using the two in combination
allows detection of some of these other
patients while at an early stage this
was a study that comes from Athens in
which the author's showed a similar
principle of the additive value of
Pisgah 2 and AFP L 3 the authors
examined 60 patients with HCC who had
AFP levels below the diagnostic level of
200 with the majority having an AFP
level less than 50
although 20% of patients had an elevated
AFP level AFP L 3 level and 20% and
elevated pivot to level there were 40
percent of patients who only had one of
the two biomarkers elevated of no 40%
had 9
two biomarkers elevated highlighting the
novel biomarkers are still needed in
terms of biomarkers I'd like to end
briefly discussing the gala score which
really ties together nicely the
complementary nature of these biomarkers
like we discussed today so to quickly
review this is a scoring system that
includes gender age AFP afplt and Pisgah
- the score was developed in a phase 2
study from the UK comparing HEC patients
and those with chronic liver disease of
a mixed etiology this score was recently
valued validated in a multicenter phase
2 study using cohorts with over 5,000
patients from Germany and Japan
published in clinical gastronome
clinical gastroenterology and hepatology
earlier this year you can see that the
sensitivities of the gala score in the
Germany cohort in Japan court were 88%
of 71 percent respectively with high
specificities in both cohorts the AUC
for early htc detection in both courts
approached 0.9 which is excellent there
was little variation in model
performance based on liver disease
etiology including viral and non-viral
mediated cirrhosis so we would need a
lot of data for the top three biomarkers
that have been in development AFP AF P
l3 and Pisgah - going back to the phases
of biomarker development AFP is the only
biomarker that has gone through all five
phases of biomarker development
including a randomized trial showing its
ability to detect HEC and clinical
practice other biomarkers including AF P
l3 and pizza and Pisgah to have
completed phase 2 biomarker data that is
case control data and we reviewed most
of that data however there have yet to
be high-quality phase 3 or phase four
data with any of these biomarkers this
can be quite difficult as they require a
longitudinal data collection and sample
collection which not only takes time
what can take a lot of money to do the
good news is that there are a couple
large cohort studies in the United
States that will become available for
face to be biomarker studies there first
is a hepatocellular carcinoma early
detection strategies study this is a
multicenter study with seven academic
centers throughout the United States
there are approximately 1,100 patients
with cirrhosis who are currently
enrolled and the goal is to enroll 1500
patients by the end of this next year
patients will be followed for five years
with every six months surveillance
patients will have serum and plasma
collected at each of these time points
building a repository for future
biomarker development the second is a
multi-site cohort stuff a cohort study
that is starting to enroll patients
across five centers in Texas this effort
is funded by the Cancer Prevention
Research Institute of Texas and will
enroll 3,000 patients with cirrhosis
over the next one to two years the
cohort compared to the hepatocellular
carcinoma early detection strategy study
will have an increased focus on
Hispanics as well as Nash cirrhosis and
will primarily enroll those patients but
once again will have a mixed etiology of
cirrhosis overall these patients once
again will be followed every six months
with imaging and serum collection
building a repository for future
biomarker discovery and validation so
we've reviewed a lot of the data for
these biomarkers but you can you can see
from the different surveillance
algorithms that have been adopted in the
year in Europe in the u.s. compared to
Japan that they may need different
interpretations of this same data so
when you take a look at what's typically
done in the United States in Europe it's
typically surveillance that's done every
six months primarily focusing on
patients with cirrhosis and you can see
in Japan that when you take a look at
patients with cirrhosis the surveillance
interval is shorter so 3 to 4 months
instead of six months although it may be
longer for patients who have other risk
factors such as non non Sarada chronic
hepatitis B typically the easel and Ald
guidelines recommend surveillance using
ultrasound alone
where
in Japan surveillance is typically done
using a complementary nature of both
imaging and biomarkers and surveillance
methods can include not only ultrasound
but inclusion of biomarkers I'll feed a
protein picket to an AFP l3 as we
discussed and can include using CTS as
well as a of its MRI every six months in
some patients now in the United States
in Europe there have been some there has
been some adoption of CT and/or MRI
every six to 12 months when ultrasound
is suboptimal although once again this
is not advocated by either of those
guideline society and you can see in in
Japan that surveillance with ear this
MRI every six to twelve months is
routinely adopted when ultrasound is
felt to be suboptimal so you can see
once again looking at the same data
different guidelines as well as
different providers in different areas
can can interpret these data very
differently and adopt very different
strategies to help these patients
so in summary HCC surveillance is
associated with early detection and
improve survival in patients with
cirrhosis although as a casus ultrasound
appears to be operator dependent and has
a suboptimal sensitivity in clinical
practice
AFP appears to be a minimal additional
benefit in settings with high quality
ultrasound however it appears to be a
benefit in most clinical practices where
ultrasound quality may not be as good a
FP accuracy may be improved through
methods such as adjustment for hepatic
inflammation and/or use of longitudinal
measurements initial data regarding AFP
l3 was a bit disappointing but recent
phase 2 studies are more promising phase
3 studies are needed to evaluate the new
highly sensitive AFP l3 assays and I
know that this is planned as part of the
hepatocellular carcinoma early detection
strategy study
similarly Pisgah 2 shows promise and
phase 2 studies but phase 3 data are
needed and once again I believe this is
planned
part of the head study to further
evaluate this biomarker as well and then
combinations of biomarkers are likely
needed given the clinical heterogeneity
of HCC and this appears to truly be the
best way to optimize sensitivity and
specificity for early tumor detection in
clinical practice thank you for your
time and open to any questions at this
time when presentation dr. Singhal we're
have you completed I am oh great
excellent presentation thanks for
bringing that information to SGA before
we get started with your questions we'd
like to do a follow-up pull the poll
question will appear on your screen
please select your answer and close the
poll by clicking on the X in the right
corner thank you here's a quick reminder
about how to reach us today questions
can be sent via the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window we'll get to as many as we can
and our first question is how do you
integrate biomarkers into your current
practice so from my standpoint once
again I really take - I really pay a
portent importance to the data showing a
gap between the efficacy and
effectiveness of ultrasound and so from
my standpoint I think in most clinical
practices including my setting I believe
that ultrasound quality can be very it
can be variable and is insufficient to
when used alone and so we routinely use
biomarkers in combination with
ultrasound now in my in my experience
once again AFP is the only one that's
actually completed all five phases of
biomarker development and is the best
study and so that is the one that I use
routinely in combination with ultrasound
so my patients would with cirrhosis
receive ultrasound and alpha-fetoprotein
every six months although I think that
both AF P l3 and Pisgah two are very
promising and have you know good phase 2
data
I personally am waiting
for for phase 3 data and more data
evaluating how these should be truly be
used in clinical practice before routine
implementation in all my patients with
cirrhosis I think there are select cases
where AFP LP and ECT can be helpful even
with current data so if I have a patient
who has had normal imaging but has
continued high AFP you know in some of
those cases I may have I may check AFP
l3 and DCP to to help evaluate that that
elevated AFP and then likewise in some
patients who are truly high-risk that
I'm very concerned about HCC I think
some of the data showing the
complementary nature of these biomarkers
I may use it in select patients but
overall most of my the vast majority of
my cirrhosis patients undergoing
surveillance receive ultrasound and AFP
every six months how is the stability of
the Pisgah biomarker so the stability I
guess can you clarify the question well
um the person um I would invite this
person to UM to clarify further please
please do so so um you mean me I mean I
guess I guess I'll I'll answer is I says
I think that the the question is meant
but I guess if clarification comes in
then I didn't answer it and once again
I'm happy to to reenter the question so
um you know I think from from a
standpoint of pivot to or DCP the
biomarker is stable in the sense of its
able to be measured and it's able to you
know be measured in routine serum
collection and so there really isn't any
fear of using it in clinical practice in
terms of stability how relevant is the
analytical performance of a FPS AIDS
when assessing longitudinal changes in
AFP levels in HD
surveillance in other words what is a
significant difference in AFP level yeah
so I mean I don't think that we know
exactly like if an AFP level goes from
you know 15 to 19 we don't have the
exact cutoff in terms of what increase
you should start getting worried about I
think that the bigger thing that I take
a look at is is the trend overall so if
if I see somebody who has an elevated
biomarker like an elevated AFP of of 25
and then I recheck it and it's 23 and
then the next time it's 29 and then the
next time it's 26 and wavers around a
stable level then I am less worried
about that patient than I am somebody
who goes from even a low level AFP level
of like 8 that then goes to 15 that then
goes to 23 to 27 so I take a look at
this in terms of a trend rather than any
one specific increase of you know for
nanograms per milliliter or you know a
tannic nanograms per milliliter I think
really the trend over time is really the
best way to look at this given the
emerging genomic data that categorizes
HCC into sub classes enriched for
etiologies HPV seems genetically
distinct from CV EtOH has this influence
subgroup analyses dgv specific markers
that may be useful in only HPV or eg Oh
H yeah I think that you know I think
that's really where we need to go with
HTC surveillance is really more
personalized HTC surveillance algorithms
I think that our current approach of
using whether it's ultrasound or up some
and AFP or is is really outdated these
days and so you know in many of the
other cancer screening programs they've
gone to much more tailored algorithms
depending at either on clinical factors
or on underlying genetics and so I think
that that's really what we have to start
doing in terms of patients with
cirrhosis
is finding you know whether it's
clinical factors such as simply
hepatitis C versus non viral or if it's
molecular markers that would say you
know based on this patient's underlying
risk or underlying clinical features we
should use this surveillance algorithm
and I think that really is hopefully
going to be the future of HIV
surveillance unfortunately I don't think
we're there yet are there any side
effect if a patient is doing ultrasound
every six months in his life since his
twenties ultrasound is it's one of the
nice things about ultrasound is that
it's a safe test there's no radiation
there's really no no harm that you know
comes from doing the ultrasound itself
now of course this is in contrast to CT
scans where you get both radiation and
contrast and so there's two things of
note and this is I think at least in my
opinion why CT surveillance should not
be done is because of the harms of doing
CT scans and then when you take a look
and you consider both ultrasound and
alpha-fetoprotein
or you know a SPL three or Pisgah two
even though there's no direct harms from
doing those biomarkers or doing the
ultrasound there are hunters that can
come from the downstream follow-up
procedures if they are falsely positive
and so I would say in terms of answering
this question I think ultrasound itself
is very safe and I wouldn't be worried
about any cumulative harm even if
they've been getting this for you know
since their 20s and so getting this for
6070 years I wouldn't be worried about
that it would be more so any potential
harm from from getting follow up you
know diagnostic testing for false
positives gotta be finding in form the
assessment of treatment efficacy so uh I
think that in terms of I mean of course
the the correlation between you know
surveillance and to
and advocacy is really the ability to
find tumors at an early stage and so you
know the biggest driver of prognosis for
HTC once again is finding tumors at an
early stage when we have curative
therapies available and so if we find
tumors at an early stage they can
undergo resection ablation liver
transplantation and have you know 5-year
survival rates approaching 70% and I
think that that is why there is such a
big push to try to optimize sensitivity
for finding tumors at an early stage and
I think that what we want to do is we
want to try to use you know imaging and
environmentally Inc to optimize the
proportion of patients found at an early
stage but in terms of you know specific
surveillance modalities influencing a
treatment effectiveness or efficacy it
doesn't necessarily matter it really is
just a matter of finding the tumors at
an early stage looks like we have time
for one last question and it is do you
have a correlation or correlation data
between AFP and HPV virus loads so AFP
in chronic hepatitis B patients is it
acts similarly in terms of the patients
with hepatitis C both the hepatitis B
and hepatitis C patients can have false
elevations in the alpha 2 protein that
are driven by the underlying hepatic
inflammation driven by the virus and so
you know patients who have inflammation
driven by the ab Pettis B can also have
elevated alpha-fetoprotein bubbles that
are falsely elevated so I think that in
terms of both chronic hepatitis C and
chronic hepatitis B might at least the
data that I've seen in my understanding
is that the AFP elevations are more
driven by the ALP level rather than the
virus level itself are there any other
we're going to have one more question
for one more there any other uses for
these markers beyond surveillance for
instance prognosis monitoring the
severity
the tumour yeah so there you know there
are data that show for let's say for AFP
there are data that show that patients
with a high AFP often have higher rates
of recurrence after liver
transplantation resection or ablation so
and then you know there's a there's data
showing that patients who have elevated
very high elevations of AFP Pitka - or
AFP l3 have higher rates of vascular
invasion and or metastatic disease so
they are related to not only tumor
burden but - related to prognosis so in
similar to the gala score there's
actually another score called the
ballade score which incorporates these
three biomarkers and has been shown to
correlate with prognosis very well so I
think that there there is a potential
role for you know all three of these
biomarkers in terms of prognosis but I
think similar to where they are in
surveillance I think that really you
know more data is needed there but I
think that we're closer probably to
using actually them in prognosis than we
are in surveillance in my opinion I
would like to once again thank dr. Amit
Singhal for his presentation do you have
any final comments um I guess this is a
thing in general this is an exciting
time because I think for for many years
all we had was ultra sound and and AFP
and I think that the fact that these
particularly these two biomarkers are
getting closer to to having you know
high-quality data and getting closer to
the phase three validation I think it's
an exciting time because I think that we
really are now going to be able to
hopefully make strides in terms of
improving early detection for patients
that develop HCC great um I would also
like to thank our sponsor Abbott for
making it possible to bring this
presentation to you
this webinar has been approved for
continuing educational credits please
click on the CD button at the bottom
left corner and follow the process to
receive your credits today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through January 14th 2017 you'll receive
an email from us alerting me when it's
available on-demand and posted on
Larry's comm they're welcome to for this
announcement any colleagues who weren't
able to join in today and can we have
you oh okay sorry um this was going to
add one more thing um thanks for logging
on participating in today's broadcast we
look forward to seeing you next time